thank you
[Music]
take a look at these five suspects who
were just arrested
I like the diversity yeah right it's
like it's like a [ __ ] up Power Rangers
degenerate Power Rangers it's like
Rangers it's like ghetto un so they did
something so bad but the story of how
like it was discovered is really like
crazy so this dude he's going back to
his mobile home that he used to live in
to pick up some old belongings is in
Augusta City Georgia right
he comes back there to pick up some
stuff uh walks in
and he sees
a beaten injured naked woman in a dog
cage in his mobile home in the mobile
home well he doesn't live there and he
don't live there nowhere he's just there
to pick up some squatter came in they
locked herself up and beat her squatters
uh maybe so he walks in and he sees her
and she's like help me
God and um another woman is also in the
room and that woman goes yeah she stole
some [ __ ] for me so I'm gonna make her
work it off uh until she pays it back
this isn't his mobile home no he used to
live there he's picking up some [ __ ]
that he left like like some mail so like
this other woman is like yeah we're
gonna we're gonna make her sex slaves
and we're gonna pimp her out until she
pays us back for what she stole I just
plainly [ __ ] says it and then another
guy in the room is like yeah there's a
bunch of dudes coming right now to have
their way with her like they're just so
[ __ ] straight up like telling him the
business plan matter of fact yeah how do
they find the cage big enough sorry it's
so German Shepherd extra large ones
mobile home it's already so small
mobiles are big dude like 1350 I don't
think they're worried about the the
comfort for this lady I think because
yeah uh if when you go to like home
should be able to hold like a sex slave
in it yeah yeah
how tiny is the sex slave
she's like a [ __ ] miniature person
[Laughter]
it's a Chia
so they [ __ ] uh so the guy walks out
and he's like holy [ __ ] like he knows
that if he Rats on him they're probably
gonna retaliate or kill him or some [ __ ]
but he goes you know what [ __ ] it I get
I gotta help this woman so he calls the
cops he rats he calls the cops they go
and they rescue her and they arrested
those five people in connection with
this abduction slash pimp out damn no
[ __ ] which guy was like I was just
there for the [ __ ] man I wouldn't do
anything wrong I don't think I don't
think five of them had this one sex
slave yeah I mean these are the five
people responsible for this whole thing
two of them were on the way my question
was what did she steal that was so
that's my question too did she steal
like a person who knows if that's even
the real like maybe she didn't sell
anything they just kidnapped her off the
streets
I think they had some kind of logic
behind it yeah how the [ __ ] are all five
of them involved two of them were on the
way one of them one of them's a manager
the other person is out getting out like
they don't chill together that doesn't
look like a lunch table at like this
lady looks like she was like works at a
library
look like a Super Saiyan yeah she's
Dewey Decimal this is this lady actually
reminds me of you know that doll and
Rugrats the doll that the oh yeah
or Hey Arnold yeah yeah this is a very
Multicultural cooperation I like the
homie that was like take my picture and
he was like
I think I think this is the woman that
was saying that [ __ ] that about the
stuff being stolen oh that's a woman it
actually looks like that Nick that's the
person I was like so that's a woman then
Nick no way I agree
that's a woman you think so yeah he's a
woman yeah it's not [ __ ] the bully
for Power Rangers
she looks like Dylan claybold who's that
Dylan sounds like a dude one of the uh
the Columbine shooters dude oh yeah I
agree from here do you remember she
looks like a woman that would pack a
lunch for someone and I don't know lunch
lady yeah and then I think this is the
guy that was saying that like yeah we've
got some dudes coming over now who are
the dudes that were coming over are they
they didn't get there if if her story is
true like from the outside world it
seems pretty nuts but then those are
just the rules of their streets you're
like she stole exactly yeah because
she's got to pay it off the norm and
then this it's that that's their
ecosystem you know when I found like
Waters in a house like nearby in
Hollywood this is kind of how they
looked like squatters are very
multi-cultural [ __ ] cast of Captain
Planet [ __ ] yeah yeah
looks like a really really dystopian
Captain Planet it wasn't even like which
ones which ones are yeah what are their
powers in the mix of races though like
this girl looks like she works at a
library
keeps saying that she looks like she's
she's has to pay off her student loans
like she doesn't look like she's in
yearbook I don't know I think there is a
common ground though like they're
combined by Meth you know what I mean
like they're like we might be different
we're different cultures I'm rich I'm
poor I work at a gas station but we all
like math no we love math yeah
we're [ __ ] high what do you think
what do you think her power is Joe
heroin [ __ ] Super Saiyan dude she
goes heroine crap
when they came to rescue her there's
like the description saying that she was
like scared to leave the cage because
she was so like [ __ ] up her eye was
like falling off like they [ __ ] her up
like they beat her yeah so she was like
super scared like wasn't sure if she
could trust them oh she was like Reek
from Game of Thrones they don't know how
long she was in there they don't know
like how how much stuff she went through
oh god oh yeah they just disassociated
from this and yeah me too I'm gonna
Pretender it's not real like a jokey
that's all you could do that's hilarious
it looks like a gag
those eyeglasses the Springs yeah
just like a awuga gone wrong yes
she looked at a beautiful woman too long
and she had a roller tongue back up too
yeah yeah now we're now it's all good so
instead of the Avengers
instead of the Avengers they're the
traffickers yeah and then they come
together to traffic somebody they
combined they combine their forces they
could buy their networks together what
is this Arkansas people yeah the
traffickers
we can traffic anything it's crazy guys
the guys are only 18 and 19. whoa young
gun that looks super old it's the meth
problems
is a hell of a drugs yeah dude so they
they arrested them and I guess like some
of them of course had priors and [ __ ]
but no way yes you would never think
right oh God I feel so bad for this
[ __ ] girl the punishment for the rat
is what would you say he gets his mobile
hold back for the wrap because it
definitely did all ratted on each other
they ratted their business to the
stranger they really so they're the
stupid rats and then he [ __ ] ratted
to the police all of them should get
spanked oh so here's what's going on
we're gonna pimp her out to pay debts I
mean how is that not them riding on them
yeah the complete stranger walks in and
goes don't worry about this [ __ ] she
stole from us like he's gonna be like oh
okay they're just excited about their
new business plan that guy is dumb
though if he still has mail being sent
to that house
you know what I mean like if his name is
attached to the address like they just
go oh like just go to the PO by our
mailbox and then just Trace what other
addresses are linked to like what where
does he want the mail forwarded to I
mean he he could have just gone on USPS
and [ __ ] forward it to his new
address
so stupid practical you guys only did it
for a year though and then they want to
charge you for can you imagine walking
into a thing like let's say you had like
an offer up sale and you went into the
person's house and you saw some [ __ ]
like that then you had to like I'd be
like does the girl come with us okay
so you know because my way I see because
I'm not a I'm not a rat and then the way
I rescue people is by bartering is by
pretending to be one of them
look here okay so like you're gonna
incriminate yourself too this is good
Joe I'm just like checking with joke
It's Kind he's like I was rescuing her
yeah
a PlayStation all right check this out
I'll give you a PlayStation and I'll
give you two of your favorite games
they're like oh [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
sick ass deal all right well let's go
and then I get her out of the situation
and then we're saved yeah sex slave in a
cage she's I don't well if the cage
comes along with that I guess I'll keep
it but it's not I'm not gonna keep her
in the cage cages are kind of expensive
they're kind of expensive it's a lot of
metal that's true if you have ever had a
big dog they're huge like fifty dollars
yeah
Joe's idea is good though because then
he's walking out of there with the girl
and then they're like FBI freeze you
[ __ ] sucking piece of [ __ ] and then
Joe's like oh no no this was I was
trying to get her out of there that's
what I would say like he's like I'm
getting arrested he's like wait I was
rescuing operating with my story she's
gonna be like no he's [ __ ] Gonna Save
Me he bought me for a Playstation and
two of their favorite games exactly have
you ever walked into a situation it's
not what it looks like I wasn't gonna
[ __ ] her
how about that yeah oh that's good and
then they'll be like I didn't want to an
orgy one time how did that happen it was
at the Playboy Mansion oh that's it
opened the wrong door
what what type of work were they like
this
there was a lot of nakedness and I just
does
oh we got a new one or like was there
any notable smells uh I just I I just it
was would you open it go oh [ __ ] yeah
well because it was in the game room it
was like the separate groom like there's
a game room that's like a separate like
Guest House basically and so I was like
oh cool it's like a room filled with
games and then you open one door and
it's like not the door you should have
opened that you shouldn't open that door
but like the rest of us like arcade
games and air hockey wow just one door
away do you think there's a guy who's
like yeah he's like I heard there's an
orgy but I keep finding those arcade
games and [ __ ] it's cruising USA doing
in here I came here for Speedball
[Laughter]
yeah did it look like what was their
reaction like ah no was it just like no
they business is usually because they're
probably just like are you at three
o'clock yeah no they can't I don't even
know if they knew the door opened well
to be honest I was just like nope in the
throat
Frozen was it hot people no oh really
you could tell them
all the best games no yeah it was not
like like beautiful models [ __ ] each
other no no really I was scamming in all
of this you're just laying down he was
drugging people he only comes out for
certain parties oh so he stays there but
he's like I'm tired of the party yeah
like he'll make an appearance but there
he only makes four half appearances a
year there's like the rest of the
parties every weekend are just like
they're not they rented out a year wow
yeah and they're they're really private
like you get like a special invitation
and damn in the mail also they weren't
[ __ ] having sex with all the Playboy
bunnies huh well they might have been uh
but I I don't know I couldn't tell the
women but the guys were not like they
were all older and like yeah
[Music]
foreign